[Music]
it's a good day to be a pirate
amaro and his four mateys bart charlotte
daniel and eliza have struck gold a
chest with 100 coins
but now they must divvy up the booty
according to the pirate code
as captain amaro gets to propose how to
distribute the coins
then each pirate including amaro himself
gets to vote either yar or nay
if the vote passes or if there's a tie
the coins are divided according to plan
but if the majority votes nay amaro must
walk the plank and bart becomes captain
then bart gets to propose a new
distribution and all remaining pirates
vote again
if his plan is rejected he walks the
plank too and charlotte takes his place
this process repeats with the captain's
hat moving to daniel and then eliza
until either a proposal is accepted or
there's only one pirate left naturally
each pirate wants to stay alive while
getting as much gold as possible
but being pirates none of them trust
each other so they can't collaborate in
advance
and being bloodthirsty pirates if anyone
thinks they'll end up with the same
amount of gold either way they'll vote
to make the captain walk the plank just
for fun
finally each pirate is excellent at
logical deduction and knows that the
others are too
what distribution should amarrow propose
to make sure he lives
if we follow our intuition it seems like
amaro should try to bribe the other
pirates with most of the gold to
increase the chances of his plan being
accepted
but it turns out he can do much better
than that why
like we said the pirates all know each
other to be top-notch logicians
so when each votes they won't just be
thinking about the current proposal but
about all possible outcomes down the
line
and because the rank order is known in
advance each can accurately predict how
the others would vote in any situation
and adjust their own votes accordingly
because eliza's last she has the most
outcomes to consider so let's start by
following her thought process she'd
reason this out by working backwards
from the last possible scenario with
only her and daniel remaining
daniel would obviously propose to keep
all the gold and eliza's one vote would
not be enough to override him so eliza
wants to avoid this situation at all
costs
now we move to the previous decision
point with three pirates left and
charlotte making the proposal
everyone knows that if she's outvoted
the decision moves to daniel who will
then get all the gold while eliza gets
nothing
so to secure eliza's vote charlotte only
needs to offer her slightly more than
nothing
one coin
since this ensures her support charlotte
doesn't need to offer daniel anything at
all
what if there are four pirates as
captain bart would still only need one
other vote for his plan to pass
he knows that daniel wouldn't want the
decision to pass to charlotte so he
would offer daniel one coin for his
support with nothing for charlotte or
eliza
now we're back at the initial vote with
all five pirates standing
having considered all the other
scenarios amaro knows that if he goes
overboard the decision comes down to
bart which would be bad news for
charlotte and eliza
so he offers them one coin each keeping
98 for himself
bart and daniel vote nay but charlotte
and eliza grudgingly vote yar
knowing that the alternative would be
worse for them
the pirate game involves some
interesting concepts from game theory
one is the concept of common knowledge
where each person is aware of what the
others know and uses this to predict
their reasoning
and the final distribution is an example
of a nash equilibrium where each player
knows every other player's strategy and
chooses theirs accordingly
even though it may lead to a worse
outcome for everyone than cooperating
would no individual player can benefit
by changing their strategy
so it looks like amaro gets to keep most
of the gold and the other pirates might
need to find better ways to use those
impressive logic skills
like revising this absurd pirate code
[Music]
you